the jurogan experience because there's a
whole
another level of training to wu tang
like if you specifically put wu-tang on
to train yeah like i kind of get your
mentality and that that
internal yeah you know feeling that you
get because yeah that's one of my not my
last fight but the fight before i walked
out to protect your neck yes and like
that just that mentality like that yeah
the beat and the drums oh yeah you just
feel like this this
i don't know like a badass martial art
like a street martial artist when we
drive to shows like when we leave the
hotel and then we go to the arena
whenever i'm doing comedy we listen to
protect your neck that's the first thing
we listen to we get in the car either
gravel pit or protect your neck a gravel
pit's crazy right
it's just i get it man that era of
hip-hop to me is just like i mean i
obviously i'm old so like that era was
when i was young and it was like when i
was really getting into hip-hop but
there's something about that era of
hip-hop because it was hip-hop was only
a couple of decades old then you know
really didn't i mean sugar hill gang was
like what 1979
78 like when
when was um rapper's delight who i mean
way before my time i was born 90 so like
i was like 78 or 79. it could have been
remember it could have been do you know
18 okay so yeah so that's that's when
rap was essentially modern rap was
essentially born
and then you know 10 years later 15
years later you know you got cool g rap
and dj polo you got all those 90s
hip-hop guys yep you know correct that's
officially released on september 16th
1917. wow there you go did you get to
see the uh wu tang saga at all on hulu
no ah joe
you gotta watch it oh my god yeah okay i
hadn't been excited about a show in a
long time and i saw the wu-tang saga
and some people have certain you know
whatever their opinions on it but i
think to be able to see
the background of every single member of
wu-tang right so it follows the like
each character individually and how they
all came together
and um
ashton sanders saunders who plays the
the rizza
and just there's a scene in season two
where
he's sampling the music and
it takes him into this like all black
room
where
the i can't even remember the uh the
group that it that that he was sampling
but they pop up and they're each playing
their instruments and then like as he
turns it down on the keyboard or on you
know as he turns it down on the board
then like the guy's still singing but
like you can't hear him anymore
apparently he was on set for for a lot
of the like scenes and stuff just kind
of
overseeing everything or giving his
input on like you know this is how it is
but yeah being someone who loves to make
music and produce beats and stuff it
when i saw that scene like i had to
rewind it i had to replay it because i'm
like yeah exactly you when you're
listening when you're trying to create
music and maybe if you're sampling you
might just hear the guitar and you don't
want the drums or you don't want this
thing so you like turn that down and
you're like ah that's the feeling that i
want to sample so when i saw that i mean
that was season two but i was already
sold on the show before you know
how many seasons are there
i think only two and the third is coming
yeah the third one's coming out the
interesting thing about hip-hop is that
it was the first
musical genre at least
popular musical genre that sampled stuff
like in that they and they it what you
know it made the songs more interesting
because you heard a little bit of an old
song in there and you're like oh
i remember that beat but then it's all
these new lyrics over that beat that
changes what that beat is and it's like
there was this
you know there was like a lot of debate
in the early days of sampling like is
this stealing like what is this it's
like no because the other song still
exists and it's obvious that this is a
piece of that other song but it it you
know like but it enhances
new music yeah exactly it's a totally
different thing like taking little
pieces of stuff and combining it
together as an art form in and of itself
personally as a it's a it's a uh it's an
appreciation yes right it's like someone
created this masterpiece already and i
took my favorite part from it and maybe
just looped it or sped it up yeah and
then kind of made a version of it not to
like compete with
this other song but it's like an
appreciation like thank you you've just
made this amazing you know piece of
music that i can now listen to on repeat
or listen to in a way that you know
translates to me in a certain way and to
millions more i don't know i don't see
any problem with it i think it's cool
yeah it's not like they're pretending
they didn't do that you know what i mean
like stealing is like there's there's
been bans that have gotten in trouble
because they have a rift that sounds
exactly like an old rift that's on a
record and they don't give the other
band credit it's not a sample they're
just trying to copy it and then they
wind up losing all the royalties well
you know that's the business of the
business yeah everything you got to get
your cut too though right you can't be
mad at the other guy that music business
is a weird business
you know like guys who are in a band
together the band can be massive but two
guys are like the head guys in the band
and they make all the money yeah and
then the other guys get pissed you know
yeah i mean kind of going back to
wu-tang i feel like that there was a
little a little bit of that was there no
yeah there were any members in wu-tang
at one point in time right yeah
absolutely but i think one of the things
was um the guys didn't really understand
the music business rizza was like the
brains behind it he was the one who like
you know had all of the kind of like
business decisions and like hey i need
you guys to sign this i need you guys to
sign these contracts so we can get this
money to make this music and
um you know they kind of trusted him and
and did it and uh i guess it just it
didn't end up really being like a good
deal for everybody
um they go over it a little bit in the
show but i think there's another
documentary that kind of goes a little
bit more in depth you know
with all that stuff but yeah man this
business is dirty business is dirty it's
a dirty game business ah yes it is with
so many people and so many different you
know
yeah man we all got to get paid yeah
that's just the fact that they brought
those dudes together though is so
interesting that the wu-10 clan existed
at all and it's so
iconic
you know like wu-tang is probably the
most iconic hip-hop band of all time
yeah i mean off the top of my head i
really can't think of someone else to
that to compare n that doesn't no one
complains it's a different thing yeah
like wu tang is like a mindset yeah like
when dave chappelle says wu-tang has a
punch line sometimes yeah people say
something just go okay
[Laughter]
you can't use any other band
you really can't yeah you really can't
and they're i mean they're they're
they're logo they're symbol they're
known everywhere yeah you can go to
you know jakarta indonesia and it's like
they know
who wu tang is or they've seen the
symbol and the people in it vary so wild
you got old dirty bastard who was just
[ __ ] crazy and then you got the gizza
who's like he's an elite chess player
yeah and i think he's done like ted
talks and [ __ ] no the guy's a genius
yeah like a legitimate genius is a
genius yeah i think he actually
he studied and has a degree in something
like
very very pleasant yeah like something
physics yeah i think he has like a
physics degree or something like that
yeah the guy the guy's adjusting what's
his ted talk see if you can find out
what the jizz's ted talk is because i
guarantee he did a ted talk yeah look at
that the genius of science the gizza and
the science genius said tedx teen yeah i
mean what the [ __ ] man
it's incredible yeah i mean when you
listen to some of his bars you're like
wow exactly how do you put those things
together that's the other thing about
90s hip-hop and like that era and
wu-tang clan in particular like the
lyrics were so good there was you would
hear lyrics and you would just go oh
[ __ ] like how did you put those together
yeah to make that yeah you know scenario
happen and yeah
lyrics to me are everything i mean the
beat is everything too i mean it's all
together obviously but it's like man
just something about like sharp lyrics
it's it's exciting